amboise automne 2013 à l'occasion d'un
tournage je rencontre l'organe elle est
animatrice de l'architecturé du
patrimoine pour le syndicat mixte du
pays loire touraine au total 58 communes
sa mission valoriser le territoire et
son patrimoine cela paraît simple et
l'on pourrait imaginer que son métier se
résume à la visite guidée de grands
monuments historiques mais la notion de
patrimoine est bien plus complexe
aujourd'hui la notion de patrimoine elle
est très très étendue on ne parle plus
seulement que de grands patrimoines et
des grands monuments mais finalement les
lavoirs les fontaines les monuments aux
morts aussi son son patrimoine en fait
tout ce que l'homme a produit
que ce soit bâti et que ce soit des
aménagements que ce soit des objets tout
et patrimoine
pour faire ce métier il faut non
seulement des connaissances donc le
savoir en quelque sorte quels qu'ils
soient historiques
architecturales et patrimoniales même
archéologiques un peu tous les savoirs
mais il faut aussi surtout savoir
transmettre en fait c'est communiquer ce
savoir armé d'une maîtrise d'histoire
contemporaine et d'un master 2
d'histoire de l'art lauriane nombre des
expositions anime des ateliers des
stages concocte de nouveaux circuits de
visites en posant un regard neuf sur le
territoire et ses richesses ainsi elle
travaille depuis un an sur le montage
d'une exposition consacrée au monument
aux morts de la grande guerre créé dans
un élan national unique ils en sont le
témoin silencieux mémoire de pierre
c'est finalement rendre hommage à ces
monuments donner une nouvelle nouvelle
approche est finalement invité en fait à
redécouvrir ces constructions
l'histoire de cette guerre à les ancrer
dans ces petits édifices de pierre
on a des paysages remarquables en val de
loire et en particulier quand on
s'approche du patrimoine on va avoir des
patrimoines plus on va dire intime et
les monuments rentrer en partie c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le paysage
mémoriel voilà donc paysage historique
aussi donc donc voilà on aborde
différentes notions
qui vont plutôt à l'affect parce qu'on
sait que là ça concerne une guerre donc
voilà c'est un paysage plus affectif
il
les grandes étapes de travail nos
mémoires de pierres ça a été d'abord
d'identifier les monuments on va sur le
terrain on prend des photos commencent à
faire des repérages on regarde
évidemment on décrit ses monuments on va
spécifiquement noter chaque détail et
puis après il ya un terrain qu'il faut
aborder ces les archives donc il faut
aller voir évidemment ce que nous offre
toute la documentation qui a été
conservé et après il faut dépouiller
tous ces documents il faut les lire il
faut les décrypter et puis après il ya
une part évidemment d'écriture il ya la
sélection évidemment des thèmes la
sélection des photographies section des
archives et puis on arrive à dix
panneaux qui présente donc le patrimoine
de ces monuments de la grande guerre
lauriane comme les 180 animateur du
patrimoine en france travaille à
redonner vie à l'histoire de nos
territoires phénomène de mode ou métiers
d'avenir ils sont la clé de foot d'un
tourisme local où l'on serait approprié
culture et paysages pour peut-être s'en
sentir plus responsable